while latin american leaders may not
have said so publicly
most all along had been rooting for joe
biden
he begins from a concept which is very
crucial to latin americans
is that instead of putting walls
or building walls you have to work for
development
in a in an ambience of cooperation
and support but there's an exception
brazil's president jay bolsonaro who's
often described as the tropical trump
biden's recent comments about
deforestation of the amazon rainforest
outraged bolsonaro who said publicly he
was cheering for donald trump
venezuela's embattled president nicolas
maduro on the other hand
is hoping biden will consider reversing
crippling u.s economic sanctions
a new consciousness is rising in the
united states of america
and its youth and its people they no
longer want imperialist wars
they no longer want threats and looting
sources tell al jazeera that biden's
regional aides are rethinking continued
support for venezuela's opposition
leader huang guido
as interim president reportedly
described by one aid as a quote
lost cause joe biden has visited latin
america
26 times so he certainly no stranger to
this region
for starters he's promised 14 billion
dollars to central american countries
to reduce poverty and violence as a way
of tackling the immigration crisis
a very different approach from donald
trump's
meanwhile many are commenting just how
latin american president trump's
electoral challenges
are sounding latin america has had all
sorts of strong men
who decided that they would stay in
power forever or would change the
results of elections because they want
it
latin america is unlikely to become a
top priority for the next u.s
administration with perhaps the
exception of the immigration issue
but after four years of being largely
ignored
there's the expectation that it will
again be on the radar
lucia newman al jazeera santiago
let's bring in doug bander he is a
senior fellow at cato institute and a
former advisor to
late president ronald reagan he joins us
from springfield
virginia thank you for your time sir
this is
huge for fallen foreign policy right as
uh the quincy institute has been
tweeting there's probably
a bunch of world leaders on conference
calls right now trying to figure out
their next moves
well i think that's right this is a
dramatic change in administrations
both in substance but especially in tone
and a number of countries will be
looking forward to a better relationship
with the u.s
and some of them such as mohammed bin
salman of
saudi arabia and others who were
favorites
of president trump will be looking very
nervously at the
prospect of dealing with a more uh shall
we say
cautious and perhaps antagonistic united
states
let's dig down on that u.s saudi
relations have been close
under uh president trump even the
killing of jamal khashoggi
was put to one side how might abiden
administration
impact u.s saudi relations and the gcc
in general
well the president-elect has made it
very clear that he's not happy
with the conduct of mohammed bin salman
he's not happy with the horrid war
in yemen i think that relationship is
very likely to change
especially because support for saudi
arabia essentially
diminished very significantly on capitol
hill
so democrats there and some republicans
want to change
with the president that will be very
significant
now other gcc countries i think the
relationship
will remain strong kuwait oman countries
such as these
i think the biden administration will be
very happy to continue to work with
saudi arabia and the emirates especially
because of the war in yemen
will be at risk okay
uh if we're to look to israel
then uh and netanyahu how do you think
things might change there under a
binding administration
well biden is part of the democratic
wing that is still
very strongly supportive of israel on
the other hand he's not so committed to
netanyahu
and the settler movement the kind of
radical extremism that we've seen there
moreover there are a lot of democrats
especially in the house
who would like to see a rebalancing so
my guess is that biden will
remain very supportive of israel broadly
speaking
but is probably going to push the
netanyahu government especially on the
issue of the west bank
of settlers of palestinians
he's going to urge a greater effort to
reach a serious peace agreement
with the palestinians as opposed to the
trump administration
which basically made all of its efforts
on behalf of netanyahu's government
and no one else if we look at treaties
and
international organizations that trump
has distanced himself from
or even outright rejected what changes
do you think we're going to see there
i'm thinking
climate accords the world health
organization weapons treaties that sort
of thing
well almost all of the international
engagements the biden administration
will be much more supportive
the president-elect said that on day one
he would return
to the climate change treaty i think the
international
criminal court would be something he
would look at he'd certainly want to
re-initiate the start treaty with russia
this is somebody who would like to
reinvigorate american involvement with
the united nations
this will be one of the areas of
greatest change with the biden
administration
just finally uh let's talk russia
obviously
how do you think things are going to
change the relationship with vladimir
putin
rhetorically president-elect biden will
be tougher than president trump
in practice i'm not sure there will be a
lot of difference
in fact the trump administration despite
the president
has been much rougher on russia it's had
greater weapons transfers to ukraine
more u.s troops to europe
put more sanctions on russia i'm not
sure that will change
but biden will be more more forthrightly
antagonistic towards russia
but he might be willing to make a deal
perhaps they can sit down
and have a tough talk as opposed to
trump where he said
nice things but his administration went
the other way
okay thank you so much for your time
doug bander there senior fellow
at cato institute and former advisor to
late president ronald reagan